die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin schönen freitagabend ja was
ist alles passiert wir fassen für sie
zusammen der blick zum tennis und
handball gehört dazu heute wieder mit
kristin otto so ist es kein abend und
das sind unsere themen
kein durchbruch keine eskalation was die
außenminister von russland und den usa
in genf zur ukraine krise gesprochen
haben
flaute beim impfen die korona zahlen
ziehen weiter an aber in den impfzentren
wird es immer leerer
ölpest an der küste perus kilometer weit
sind strände verschmiert auslöser war
der vulkanausbruch im 10.000 kilometer
entfernten tonga
[Musik]
die ukraine krise wird seit tagen
begleitet von warnungen säbelrasseln und
internationaler diplomatie echte
fortschritte bislang fehlanzeige darum
heute der gespannte blick nach genf zum
treffen der chefdiplomaten russlands und
der usa dass die beiden sich nicht in
die arme fallen das war schon im vorfeld
klar in welcher atmosphäre die gespräche
verliefen und mit welchem ergebnis weiß
isabel schäfers die erwartungen waren
klein das gespräch mit anderthalb
stunden sehr kurz man habe sich aber
offen ausgetauscht versucht die
gegenseitigen positionen zu verstehen
dennoch sieht der us außenminister klar
russland in der verantwortung fordert
erneut das ende russischer provokation
gegenüber der ukraine
weissrussland steht nun vor der wahl
geht es in diplomatischen weg der zu
frieden und sicherheit führt oder den
weg des konflikts der zu ernsten
konsequenzen und internationaler
verurteilung führen wird gerade heute
schickt das russische
verteidigungsministerium wieder bilder
in die welt bilder die daran zweifeln
lassen dass moskau auf die eskalation
setzt für eine übung im februar werden
material und soldaten nach belarus
verlegt an die ukrainische grenze der
russische außenminister lavrov sieht
darin aber keine provokation im
gegenteil der westen und die ukraine
seien schuld am konflikt ruth immer
wieder wird behauptet
die ukraine angreifen obwohl wir doch
immer wieder erklären dass wir das nicht
tun werden auch in berlin heißt es heute
fortlaufende gespräche seien jetzt
wichtig bundeskanzler scholz betont
erneut dass jede militärische aktion
russlands einen hohen preis hätte noch
mehr geht es aber darum jetzt alles
notwendige zu tun dass wir verhindern
dass es zu einer solchen militärischen
aggression kommt nächste woche wollen
die usa schriftlich auf einen
forderungskatalog russlands reagieren
danach soll es weitere gespräche geben
damit wären immerhin die kleinen
erwartungen an das heutige treffen
erfüllt
florian hahn ist für uns dabei in gent
florian keine eskalation aber echte
deeskalation auch nicht sondern
es ist zumindest mal würde ich sagen
eine kleine atempause man hat sich hier
in genf durchaus etwas zeit kaufen
können in diesem konflikt einerseits
haben hier heute eben beide seiten den
willen zum dialog betont vor allem vom
russischen außenminister lawrow hatte
man so etwas zuletzt eher nicht gehört
andererseits aber hatte es in den
inhaltlichen fragen keinerlei zeichen
von entspannung oder gar von kompromiss
oder rückzugs bereitschaft gegeben
insofern bleibt die große frage wie
reagiert russland wenn die usa wie
angekündigt nächste woche diese antwort
auf die russischen fragen schicken
werden denn weiterhin ist klar dass der
westen nicht auf die russischen
maximalforderungen eingehen wird etwa
auf die frage nach dem abzug von nato
soldaten aus osteuropa insofern ist
könnte dann zu einem dialog kommen auf
präsidenten ebene zwischen beiden und
putin oder es kommt doch noch zu der
angekündigten und befürchteten
eskalation
danke nach genf florian neumann jetzt
der blick auf die aktuellen kroner
zahlen zeigt auch heute wieder nie
dagewesene höchststände das rk ii meldet
140.000 160 neuinfektionen binnen 24
stunden das sind 47
1937 mehr als vergangenen freitag
170 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage ins ident steigt erstmals über 700
auf jetzt 7 106,3
für experten ist sicher der weg aus der
pandemie für nur über eine hohe
impfquoten rund 73 prozent der
bevölkerung ist inzwischen mindestens
zweimal geimpft die bisher meisten
impfungen die gab es am 15 dezember des
vergangenen jahres mit 1,6 millionen
dosen viele impfzentren wurden damals
wieder hoch gefahren aber die zahl der
impfwilligen nimmt wieder ab gestern
wurden 640 000 impfdosen verabreicht
495.000 davon waren auffrischungsimpfung
und nur wenige haben sich zum ersten mal
impfen lassen sven glas berichtet
wenig los in dieser stuttgarter in
station manche kabinen vorübergehend
außer betrieb genommen rund 1000
impfungen sind es im moment am tag es
waren schon mal 4000 und doch kommen
noch menschen die meisten zum boostern
ganz selten aber auch welche bei denen
es die erste impfung ist
und deswegen habe ich dann gedacht okay
das ist wirklich wahr dass es komplett
19 gibt's dann habe ich mich entschieden
habe sagt okay jetzt muss ich für zu
nehmen in diesem station ist sie
gekommen weil termine hier inzwischen
schnell und einfach verfügbar sind auch
deshalb appellieren die betreiber die
station mitten in der fußgängerzone
offen zu halten trotz derzeit niedriger
nachfrage nutzen einer impfung für den
einzelnen und die gesellschaft ist
riesig es lohnt sicherlich auch leicht
über ausgestattete kapazitäten
vorzuhalten schon bald könnte es auch
wieder mehr andrang geben falls eine
vierte impfung empfohlen wird wenn ein
angepasster omikron impfstoff kommt oder
eine allgemeine impfpflicht nach omikron
wird ja dass wir uns nicht aus der welt
sein und wir werden auch das ist eine
sehr eindeutige aussage aus der
wissenschaft dann mit wieder neuen virus
form zu tun haben und wenn wir uns
ernsthaft schützen wollen dann brauchen
wir wirklich eine ganz hohe impfquote in
der ganzen gesellschaft termin engpässe
lange schlangen wie es sie ende letzten
jahres gab sollten daher vermieden
werden damals war kurz nach der
komplette schließung der meisten
größeren impfzentren bundesweit die impf
nachfrage sprunghaft wieder angestiegen
nun will man etwa in baden württemberg
besser gewappnet sein die zahl der
impfstellen zwar vorübergehend
reduzieren aber nicht komplett
zurückbauen um sie schnell hochfahren zu
können falls wieder mehr impfungen
nachgefragt werden
kurz vor dem bundesliga wochenende
dürfte das vor allem die fans
interessieren denn die zeiten der spiele
vor leeren oder fast leeren rängen
könnte bald vorbei sein vor dem bund
länder treffen am montag gibt es den
vorstoß mehr zuschauer bei sport aber
auch bei kulturveranstaltungen
zuzulassen und vor allem bayern prescht
vor andrea meuser hat die einzelheiten
geisterspiele früher als andere länder
hatte sich bayern für fußball spiele vor
leeren rängen entschieden jetzt aber
denkt ministerpräsident söder öffentlich
über eine auslastung von bis zu 50
prozent und 2 g + nach für kultur und
sport ich kann nicht einziehen ist das
auf dauer in ordnung ist wenn in hamburg
in berlin viele zuschauer dabei sind und
bei uns obwohl wir zum teil deutlich
strengere maßnahmen haben wir nicht
diese möglichkeit haben deswegen werden
wir auf jeden fall auf der mpk werben
das ziel eine bundeseinheitliche
regelung ein stadionbesuch mit maske und
abstand vermutlich nicht das problem
schwierig aber die zeit davor und danach
im stadion selber kann relativ wenig
passieren wenn man sich draußen aufhält
insbesondere wenn man abstand hält wenn
man stattdessen aber in die kneipe geht
oder nach dem spiel in die kneipe geht
oder in überfüllten bussen und bahnen
zum stadion fährt dann ist das sind das
genau die situation wo die gefahr lauert
das ende leerer plätze beim sport in der
kultur in cafés oder restaurants viele
erhoffen dass und so findet der vorstoß
unterstützer auch aus anderen bereichen
unsere forderungen sind ganz klar dass
kunst kultur veranstaltungen gastronomie
wieder öffnen dürfen unter zweig nicht
zweig plus 2 g plus ist vollkommen
unübersichtlich
wir müssen wieder positiver denken und
mutiger entscheiden und auch mehr als 25
kapazität zu lassen verschiedene
bereiche viele gemeinsamkeiten am montag
entscheiden die ministerpräsidenten
corona pandemie oder die ukraine krise
mit der welt die sendung begonnen haben
waren heute auch themen bei der ersten
kabinettsklausur der bundesregierung
kanzler scholz lud dafür ins kanzleramt
es ging auch um die großen ziele der
ampel und um tempo über pläne atmosphäre
und ankündigungen andreas huppert in
klausur gehen hieß früher die
abgeschiedenheit und ruhe hinter
klostermauern zu suchen nicht kloster
sondern kanzleramt hier hat sich die
ampelkoalition zu ihrer ersten
kabinettsklausur verabredet um sich über
die kommenden aufgaben und dringendsten
themen abzustimmen geplant war das mal
anders eigentlich wollte die klausur als
auch geselliges zusammensein geplant
haben wir das mit großem abstand und
einer gewissermaßen sterilen atmosphäre
abgehalten und dennoch gab es immer
wieder die schönen kontakte miteinander
ein bisschen zu lassen aber auch
dienstliche dinge auf dem kurzen weg
über den langen tag zu klären und die
themenpalette ist groß innenpolitisch
vorrang hat sicherlich die pandemie
bekämpfung dazu der wohnungsbau die
digitalisierung natürlich klimaschutz
und energiewende wichtigster aspekt in
all diesen bereichen es soll es muss
schneller gehen bei der umsetzung heißt
abbau von bürokratie wir haben sehr
konkret gemeinsam in allen ressort
bereichen besprochen was kann getan
werden damit deutschland tempo aufnimmt
um fortschritt zu wagen in diesem jahr
hat deutschland den g7 vorsitz inne und
plant für den sommer ein gipfeltreffen
in den bayerischen alpen dort soll es
dann primär um den weltweiten
klimaschutz gehen wir wollen erreichen
dass nicht jedes land für sich alleine
geht sondern dass sie sich zusammentun
zu einem klima club in dem auf
unterschiedliche weise aber gemeinsam
voran gekommen wird damit wir es
schaffen die man neutral in der welt zu
werden ein tag kabinettsklausur ein
symbolisches zeichen der ampel das
zeigen soll es läuft und alle im
koalitionsvertrag versprochenen
maßnahmen werden in angriff genommen
nach der bundestagswahl schlappe
versucht sich die linke in aufarbeitung
und neuausrichtung es geht um
verantwortung markenkern um
themenfindung in der opposition ein
schmerzhafter prozess den grabenkämpfe
bleiben ein ständiger begleiter andrea
maurer hat die klausur der linken
verfolgt
jahresauftaktklausur der kleinsten
oppositionspartei
nachdem 4,9 prozent debakel will sich
die linksfraktion neu auf und ausrichten
sollte wird die soziale opposition sein
und wir wissen signal auch in die
gesellschaft senden dass wir die rolle
die uns zugebilligt worden ist nach
dieser niederlage bei der bundestagswahl
dass wir die rolle annehmen steigende
energiepreise armut mieten explosion
will die linke zum thema machen und doch
ist die frage wer die partei wählen wer
sie führen soll längst zum
richtungsstreit geworden dass der nord
stream zwei befürworter klaus ernst den
vorsitz im klima ausschuss des
bundestages bekommen hat irritiert jener
die die nähe zur klimabewegung suchen
co-parteichefin hennig welt so nennt die
wahl von ernst als beispiel für die
zitat in fremden in den politischen
zielsetzungen und der strategie zwischen
partei und fraktionsspitze ernst schlägt
nun zurückfordert mitglieder votum und
neuwahl der parteiführung ich hatte den
eindruck dass hier der vorstand unsere
partei ihr wenig verantwortung auf sich
selbst bezogen hat und diese mich hat
den vorschlag gemacht dass der vorstand
wie zum beispiel auch bei der cdu das
war die haben verantwortung übernommen
haben sich selbst zur wahl gestellt
erneut und zwar aufgrund eines
mitglieder votum darüber diskutieren wie
wir zu verfahren kommen ich halte es
aber für so lud notwendig dass die linke
jetzt auch wieder mit inhalten nach
vorne geht und ausstrahlt wir wollen
gesellschaft verändern und uns nicht
primär mit uns selber beschäftigen aber
klar ist wir müssen die wahlniederlage
aufarbeiten nächsten dienstag treffen
fraktion und parteivorstand zu einer
aussprache aufeinander es könnte wohl
auch darum gehen mit wem und wie es
weitergeht
nach den enthüllungen zum sexuellen
missbrauch im erzbistum münchen und
freising fordern politiker
opfervertreter und katholische laien
eine vollständige aufklärung aus dem
justizministerium hieß es die
aufarbeitung sei keine innere
angelegenheit der kirche opfervertreter
fordern dass der skandal von
unabhängigen stellen aufgeklärt wird die
staatsanwaltschaft münchen prüft ob 42
aktive geistliche kinder und jugendliche
sexuell missbraucht haben in peru hat
die regierung den ökologische notstand
ausgerufen grund ist ein sich
ausbreitende ölteppich der bislang schon
mehr als 20 strände verschmutzt hat das
unglück ist eine der folgen des
vulkanausbruchs in tonga vor einer woche
die eruption hatte einen tsunami
ausgelöst der auch das mehrere tausend
kilometer entfernte peru erreichte aus
einer raffinerie nördlich der hauptstadt
lima liefen große mengen öl ins meer
christoph distel
das gefieder verklebt die vögel
ausgekühlt vielleicht am verschluckten
öl gestorben und selbst die die noch
leben haben kaum chancen durchzukommen
wie viel öl da vor der küste treibt
lässt die hand im wasser zumindest
erahnen verantwortliche vor ort sind
fassungslos
das ist ein angriff auf die
biodiversität unsere küstenlinie unsere
strände die wahrheit ist wir haben hier
ein umweltdesaster das
10.000 kilometer entfernt begann mit dem
ausbruch des unterwasservulkans in tonga
15 stunden später trifft die
tsunami-welle auch in peru auf land bei
einer raffinerie des spanischen konzerns
repsol wird gerade ein tanker entladen
als die tsunamiwelle ihn durchrüttelt 25
liter öl ins meer geraten meldet repsol
erst doch der schwarze teppich wächst
nach norden verschmutzt 50 kilometer
küstenlinie letzte schätzung fast eine
million liter müssen ausgetreten sein
repsol schickte ein kleines team zum
aufräumen sieht sich aber selbst nicht
verantwortlich schließlich habe peru
keine eigene tsunami-warnung
herausgegeben ein juristischer streit
bei dem es um viel geld gehen wird warum
also zögerte peru wenn doch das
internationale tsunami warnsystem sehr
wohl an schlug geologisch geantwortet
mit größter werden der entfernung nimmt
die wellenhöhe sehr stark ab von daher
ist man hier auch zunächst davon
ausgegangen auch die wissenschaft dass
es keine merkbaren tsunami in mehreren
tausend kilometer entfernung geben wird
aber für 80 zentimeter hat die energie
eben doch gereicht und diese kleine
welle für ein großes unglück dass die
vögel trifft die demonstrierenden
fischer aber auch repsol dem hat peru
jetzt schwere strafen angedroht
ungeachtet des konzerns logans
leidenschaft für die sicherheit
leidenschaft für das leben
im gewölbe des himmels wird rock
erschallen ruhe in frieden twitterte der
britische komponist andrew lloyd webber
und nahm damit abschied von meat loaf
die rock legende starb mit 74 jahren
[Musik]
do anything for love eine seiner
bekanntesten songs seine platte bat out
of hell zählt zu den meistverkauften
alben aller zeiten
der us-musiker marvin lee aday erhielt
den spitznamen meat loaf also übersetzt
hackbraten schon zu schulzeiten zu sehen
war er auch in filmen richtig berühmt
machte ihn das musical rocky horror
picture show
[Musik]
ob man sich mal wieder gerne an zum
sport jetzt und gleich mal ans andere
ende der welt gründet lohnt sich auch
richtig nach dem deutschen doppel credit
suisse hat auch alexander zverev im
einzel das achtelfinale der australian
open in melbourne erreicht bereits zum
vierten mal nacheinander der
olympiasieger nicht ganz so überzeugend
aber weiter ohne satzverlust
das war ganz schön mühsam für alexander
zverev gegen den qualifikanten radio
album immerhin gelang dem 24-jährigen
hamburger gegen den moldawier die
entscheidenden punkte
zverev in melbourne bisher noch ohne
satzverlust wird im achtelfinale gegen
den starken kanadier denis schapowalow
auf seine bessere seite zeigen müssen um
den großen traum vom ersten grand slam
erfolg lebendig zu halten
erleichterung bei den deutschen
handballern alle corona negativ thomas
skulski in bratislava allein das muss
doch für das zweite em hauptrundenspiel
gegen norwegen auftrieb geben
ja das sollte es schafft aber auch
ungewohnten luxus alfred gislason hat
eine kleine auswahl bezüglich der 16
spieler die er für diese partie
nominieren darf julius kühn übrigens hat
es nach unseren informationen noch nicht
zurück aus der quarantäne in die
mannschaft geschafft christoph steinert
immerhin heute von beginn an und er
sollte helfen dass es nicht wieder diese
schier endlosen 15 torlosen minuten gibt
wie gestern gegen spanien zwischen der
24 und 39 minute hellwach zur primetime
wäre ein gutes motto heute absolut
vielen dank thomas in knapp einer stunde
geht es also los viertel nach acht
deutschland norwegen live hier bei uns
im zdf skisprung olympiasieger andreas
wellinger ist zwei wochen vor beginn der
winterspiele corona positiv getestet
worden dadurch verpasste er sein letzte
qualifikationschance für peking
der norweger alexander olbort kinder zum
ersten mal das abfahrts rennen in
kitzbühel gewonnen der 29-jährige siegte
auf der wegen starken windes leicht
verkürzten streif vor den franzosen jo
ann klare und blaise giezendanner der
mit startnummer 43 noch aufs podest fuhr
von den fünf deutschen teilnehmern kamen
beim ersten von zwei abfahrts rennen in
kitzbühel keiner unter die besten zehn
dominik schweiger wurde vierzehnter
man biathlon weltcup in antholz war
franziska hildebrand mit vier
schießfehlern auf rang 15 zwar die mit
abstand beste deutsche doch war ihre
enttäuschung über die nicht nominierung
für die olympischen spiele in peking
umso größer im einzel über 15 kilometer
gab es ganz vorne einen französischen
doppelerfolg durch den präses buß und
chili asimo als dritter auf dem podest
die schwedin monat los
und morgen dann die staffel der frauen
generalprobe für olympia dann vielen
dank christian und wir bleiben im schnee
in einigen teilen deutschlands herrscht
nämlich wieder winter wie hier im
erzgebirge und da gibt es aktuell uns
auch eine unwetterwarnung morgen fällt
in einigen regionen dann noch mal
richtig viel neuschnee für die meisten
wird es nochmal wohl eher trübes
wochenende mehr dann gleich von katja
horneffer später gegen zehn nach neun in
der handball pause erwartet christian
sievers sie zum heute journal unser team
aus der heute 19 sagt bis morgen danke
fürs zuschauen wünscht einen entspannten
start ins wochenende
[Musik]
guten abend heute nachziehen regen
wolken von nordwesten auf und je mehr
die richtung südosten ziehen desto mehr
wird schwer raus diese schneewolken
erreichen schon in der zweiten
nachthälfte den alpenrand und morgen
über tag schneit es dort ergiebig weiter
da können so 50 bis 60 zentimeter
neuschnee zusammenkommen machen sie sich
also auch in dieser nacht wieder auf
tief winterliche straßenverhältnisse
gefasst nicht nur dort wo es schneit
oder wo schnee regen fällt sondern einen
breiten streifen von der ostseeküste bis
zum alpenrand denn überall dort sinken
die temperaturen auf kritische werte
zwischen plus zwei und minus sechs grad
im nordwesten der regen fällt bleibt ist
ein bisschen milder morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 0 grad an
den alpen und 8 grad im nordwesten und
abgesehen von dem schnee wird das morgen
ein recht trüber tag die sonne sehen sie
allenfalls man hier so zwischen berlin
und der ostseeküste am sonntag dann aber
sehen sie die sonne vor allen dingen im
süden und im südwesten und es gibt nur
noch wenige schneeregenschauer zum
beispiel in sachsen und auch im
östlichen bayern bei temperaturen von
zwei bis acht grad und in der neuen
woche geht es deutlich ruhiger weiter
bei höchsttemperaturen von null bis acht
grad guten abend